بعد طول انتظار ماسك يكشف هويه رئيس تويتر
المقبل وبين نجاحين مكسرين الدنيا في جعفر
العمده واللعبه اربعه النجمه مي كساب ضيفه
استوديو تفاعلكم والروايه الكامله لمقتل
الفنان السودانيه شادي محمد حسين اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
عدنا والعود احمد ورجعنا لكم بعد اجازه مو
طويله كثير وطبعا كالعاده وزي ما هو
ملازمنا في نشراتنا من زمان ايلون ماسك
بيستقبلنا بخبر هو عنواننا الاول فماسك يا
جماعه انهى الجدل والانتظار الطويل وكشفوا
واخيرا عن هويه رئيس تويتر الجديد تعالوا
بس نتذكر القصه من الاول ماسك من وقت ما
اشترت وتر وتراس الشركه وهو عامل جدل لعده
اسباب ومن هذه الاسباب تراسلي الشركه
فيعني في ناس شايفه انه كيف ماسك حيدير
تويتر ومعها تسلا ومعها سبيس اكس كمان هذا
غير سلسله القرارات الجدليه اللي اخذها
وطبعا غير الحاله الماديه الصعبه للشركه
وغير موجه التسريحات الكبيره اللي عملها
وامام طبعا كل هذا الصخب والانتقادات عمل
ماسك استفتاء لمتابعي في ديسمبر وسالهم هل
بتفضلوا استمر في رئاسه تويتر وتعهد
بالالتزام بالنتيجه والناس اختارت انه
يتنحى وطلع بعدها واكد انه حيتنحى وانه
قبل اخر السنه في رئيس جديد حيمسك تويتر
الخميس غرد ماسك بالمفاجاه وقال لهم خلاص
اخترت الرئيس الجديد وراح تبدا عملها
الاسابيع الجايه في التغريده ما حدد مين
لكن شوق الناس خصوصا وانه انفهم من الكلام
انها سيده وثاني يوم على طول غرض ماسك
ثاني واعلن هويه رئيس التويتر الجديده وهي
ليندا يا كروني وقال انه راح تتراس الشركه
وتركز على عملياتها فيما حيركز ماسك على
تصميم المنتجات
والتكنولوجيا الجديده الرئيس التنفيذيه
الجديده قالت بعد تعيينها انه لطالما
الهمتها رؤيه ماسك للمستقبل وانه سعيده
ومتحمسه للمساعده في تحويل هذه الرؤيه
لواقع
السؤال طبعا الكل بيساله الان مين هي
ليندا يا كروني ليندا كانت وحتى قبل
تعيينها من قبل ماسك بتشغل منصب مديره
الاعلانات في ام بي سي يونيفرسال وبتشتغل
مع الشركه من 2011 يعني من اكثر من 12 سنه
لكن من اسابيع عملت مقابله مع مصر في
مؤتمر تسويق في ميامي ويبدو انه هنا حصل
الكليك اما قبل ام بي سي يونيفرسول فلندا
بتشتغل في مجال الاعلان والتسويق من 30
سنه تقريبا وكانت اشتغلت كمان على مشاريع
مع ايام رئاسته وكمان مع بايدن خلال
رئاسته الحاليه
اللي متابع تفاعلكم اكيد عارف انه ما يكسب
من نجومنا المفضلين كفريق وضيفه دائما
معانا مع كل عمل وكل موسم بتبدع فيه في
رمضان هذا اتالق طبعا في دور ثريا في جعفر
العمده
لو الوضع
عايش
وبعد النجاح اللي مكسر الدنيا هذا في دور
ثريا ما يكمله في النجاح ما شاء الله
واليوم بيبدا عرض اولى حلقات الموسم
الرابع من مسلسل اللعبه هذا المسلسل اللي
بيعرض على شاهد وكسر الدنيا في اجزاء
الثلاثه الاولى واللي حرصت ما يعلم عبر
حساباتها انها كمان تروج له وتدعي او تدعي
كل متابعينها لمشاهدته
[موسيقى]
ادي ميار ميوره ودي بسمه بسومه وانا وسيم
وسومه
[تصفيق]
في رمضان عن بعد وعدتنا بزياره واليوم
بتوفي بالوعد ومنورتنا في الاستوديو
النجمه ما يكسب اهلا فيك معايا يا ميس
يعني انا مو سر محبتي لك وانحياز لك اصلا
بشكل عام كل سنه تعرفي انك انت مفضله عندي
حقيقي من المنحين صحيح ورمضان ده ثريا
اعتقد كلنا انحازنا يعني كان نجاح غير
مسبوق نقدر نقول في اي شيء كمسلسل لكم
كلكم كل شيء كان فيه غير مسبوق حسيتي بهذا
الشيء اه طبعا كان نجاح ساحق خصوصا وحاله
منفرده حصلت في الشارع المصري والشارع
العربي وهي تفاعل الجمهور معانا يعني بقى
الجمهور فارق معاه امتى بقى تشوفي ابنك
يعني كانت حلقه غريبه واول مره تحصل اظن
وشفتي كميه التعليقات والاشياء والنكت
اللي طلعت على الدور ايش في كذا شيء مثلا
ضحكك شفتيه وضحكك الله اكثر حاجه ضحكتني
قوي لما انا غنيت الرباع
صور لي انا واحمد سعد اللي هو ارجع ده
ابني انا
احمد هو كان بيغني عجبتني قوي جدا ضحكتني
جدا جدا وعلى سيره الرباعيه هادي كيف جاء
موضوع انك انت اللي تعمليه ايش القصه من
وراهم محمد سامي طبعا يعني
هو فكر من الاول ان رباعياتكم بصوتي اصدق
يعني وطبعا لان هو شايفني كمطربه مقصره في
حق الغناء فدلوقتي بيقول لي بقى انت
تحولتي للممثله اللي هترجع بقى تغني تغني
محمد سامي يعني بيشوف اشياء وبيفرضها يعني
بحبها خلاص ايوه فعلا صاحب وجهه نظر
منفرده يعني حقه طب نقدر نسمع شيء من
الرباعيه اه طبعا
رجع حبيبه عيني
نبض اللي
تهمني
يا اه
فرقيني
ويا هم غيب عني
[موسيقى]
ارضي اللي كانت
من حضنه طرحت نور يا قلبي يابا
[موسيقى]
انسى الوجع اغني
يا قلبي يا
ماهور
انسى الوجع غني
[موسيقى]
م المسلسل كمان يعني زي ما النجاح كان
كبير برضو ده كان في كلامه اشياء من كده
دايما دحين بيقولوا انه دايما بيجيبوا
سيرتك انت وايمان العاصي وطبعا منا فضالي
والكبيره طبعا هلا صدقي تحيه لهم كلهم
طبعا الملكه هلا صدقي لكن دايما في كلام
ما بتجيبوا سيره زينه ما بتنزلوا صور زينه
ما بتحطوا زينه ابدا معكم في الكلام انا
هتكلم عن نفسي انا زينه صديقه من زمان جدا
ليا يعني حتى من قبل ما نبقى مشهوره قوي
وهي تبقى مشهوره لسه صغيرين في بدايتنا
وزنا انسانه محترمه جدا وانا بعتز
بصداقتها وما فيش اي مشاكل بيننا احنا بس
كان يعني اغلبيه التصوير هي ما بتكونش
موجوده معانا فيه بس عشان كده ما كانش في
صور بتحصل يعني
بجد واحنا كلنا قلنا الكلام ده ما كانش في
اي مشاكل الحمد لله كانت الاجواء كويسه
جدا بيننا وده طلع ربنا هيكرمنا كل الكرم
الكبير ده لو بان حتى بعدين وانتم بتحتفوا
ببعض والنجاح والبوستات لما كل واحده فيكم
كانت تيجي اللحظه اللي دورها بصير فيه
التحول كان يعني الكل بيقلب معاها
وبيساندها والكلام ده كله لا سويته يعني
شغل حلو على السوشيال ميديا صراحه يعني
تفاعلنا مع الشاشه ومع السوشيال ميديا مع
حساباتكم بس كمان صار كلام كثير على موضوع
حتى انت قلتي انا استاهل انه يكون اسمي
بعد محمد رمضان طيب نقدر نقول انه انت
مثلا في المسلسل الكل جاي حتشطرتي انه
اسمك مثلا يكون اول اسم تاني اسم او كيف
بدك هو دي امور يعني انا بشوف انها لازم
تتحل الاول مع الانتاج قبل ما ندخل في
العمل فانا مثلا كل سنه بتعلم حاجه فاحنا
السنه دي بس كانت المشكله كبيره لان 3/
نجوم
مليان بالظبط وكل واحد بيشيل المسلسل
لوحده فكان يعني انا يعني عذرا الانتاج
والله يعني هم كانوا مش عارفين يعملوا ايه
يرضوا مين ولا مين
ده قرار من شاهد مش مننا احنا خالص اه
يعني ده قرار مسلسل لان كمان اعتقد شاهد
كان عندهم اعمال كتيره قبل رمضان ناجحه
فغالبا الريت كان عالي قوي علشان فاعتقد
بدماغ انتاجيه شويه يعني هم قالوا كده كده
برده الريت في رمضان عالي على شاهد فقال
لك اعليه بعد رمضان ازاي طبعا باللعبه لان
احنا يعني ما شاء الله اللعبه طول السنه
مش بس فتره معينه لو دحينا الحلو انه
الناس لما الرابع نزل بداوا يحضروا من
الاول اللي فاتهم من الاول بس تفضلي انه
ينزل في رمضان
يعني هي المنافسه في رمضان بيبقى لها طعم
مختلف بس انا جعفر العمده اكيد ما كنتش
عايزه حاجه تشوش على الدور لان اوردي جالي
مسلسل تاني بطولتي
يعني اعمله ورفض خلاص واخذوا احد ثاني
انعرض المسلسل لا اظن ما عملوش المسلسل
خالص بس خفت ورفضت وكده واعتذر بيستنوكي
لرمضان الجاي يمكن يا رب
رمضان الجاي ده حاجه مخوفانا كلنا يعني
بسقف
هنروح فين لازم طب اوكي والشيء الاساس
بحيث بتغني
ليه ما بترجعي بتغني
هو غصب عني شويه يعني انا يمكن الوقت اللي
غنيت فيه كانت مقاييس الساحه الغنائيه لها
مقاييس معينه وانا دايما بقول بصراحه ان
احنا كان مطربين بنفتقد المنتج الفنان انا
طول عمري نفسي اقابل منتج فنان ياخد
الموهبه ويدير الموهبه دي كويس جدا
ويعتبرها مشروعه احنا كلنا كمطربين كل
النجاحات دي اجتهادات فرديه ما فيش مؤسسه
بتشتغل عليكي وتدعمك وتقول مثلا انا عندي
مي كساب مي كساب فنانه شامله بتغني وبتمثل
يعني روتانا انا كليات تجربه معاهم وليهم
كل التقدير والاحترام بس كمان كان حظي سيء
معاهم لان انا في الوقت اللي عملت فيه
القلب مع روتانا اللي هو احلى من الكلام
بعدها هم قرروا غالبا يقفلوا فرع القاهره
او حاجه كده فما كملناش
طيب
نقدر نسمع شويه طيب نختم كده بشيء من صوتك
الحلو جوزي بيحبها اوكي طيب
تحيه طبعا
وانا لسه هصبر تاني عليك واعد وازيد غلطي
تاني انا كل مره اخد بايديك بلاقيك نسيت
في ثواني
وانا يوم ما هتعب مش هلاقيك ولا يوم
تعيشها
عشاني يا وجع قلبي كل يوم بهواك يا تعب
قلبي هعمل ايه وياك هو اللي ضحى حبيبي
معاك تكافئه بعذابه يا وجع قلبي ليه في
ناري تقيد لتيجي وتمشي من بعيد لبعيد
وكمان
عايزني انا ات
يا جرحني
بغيابك
الله الله الله انا بس حابه اقول لك حاجه
هو كانوا جالسين في الجاليه دي كلهم بداوا
يطلبوا طلبات اغاني والكلام ده كله
فنتجاهلتهم وخالتك انت اللي تختاري انت
اخترتي شيء هم كان بدهم اياه صراحه ايوه
بس حابه بس اوري حاجه انه انا وانت بتغني
انا شلت السماعه من اذني لانه بداوا يغنوا
يا حبايبي
شكرا لكم يعني انت رائعه رائعه رائعه
حبيبتي
شكرا لك كانت معنا طبعا النجمه ما يكسب
شهد محمد حسين فنانه سودانيه مخيم بسببها
الحزن على كل المنصات في السودان بعد
الاعلان عن وفاتها الروايات حول الوفاء
متضاربه في كلام عن وفاتها بصديه في كلام
ثاني عن وفاتها رميان بعد مشاده كلاميه مع
مسلحين وفي كلام عن رصاصه طائشه الفنانه
الشابه الراحله عشرينيه وهي من شمال
كردفان ونشات وترعرعت هناك ومن بعدها
انتقلت لام درمان لتكمل تعليمها في مجال
الاقتصاد والاداره وتوفت هناك في منزلها
فجر السبت ويمكن اكثر ما هو مؤلم في قصه
شادن انه اشتهرت بترديد الاغنيات الثلاثيه
والثوريه والداعيه للسلام والرافضه للحرب
وغنيها لها رواج كبير بين الشباب غير
التفاعل الكبير اللي صار على تويتر على
خبر وفاتها وترحم الملايين عليها كثار
الدواء واخر منشور لي الراحله واللي كان
على فيسبوك وفي كانت بتشكو من الاوضاع
الصعبه وبتتكلم عن النهب والجوع والرعب
وقالت في اخر البوست لو متنا حنموت
بكرامتنا واخلاقنا وما حنقابل ربنا شايلين
حق مو حقنا
من الخرطوم معنا الصحفي في قناه العربيه
الشهدي نادر اهلا فيك معنا شهدي ايش بنعرف
يعني في تضارب في الروايات ايش القصه مثلا
اللي تقدر تقول انها يعني قد تكون الادق
نعم
بحسب ما فائده مع فادنا احد افراد اسرتها
تحدثنا معها معه قبل قليل قال لنا بانهم
كانوا يتواجدون اعلى منزلهم كانوا يشاهدون
بعض بعض الاشتباكات التي كانت تجري على
مقربه منهم هي تسكن في مدينه ام درمان
وتحديدا في حي الهاشماب هو حي شرقه مباشره
تقع مستشفى الولاده ام درمان التي
التي تتواجد بها قوات الدعم السريع وشرقي
منها يقع مقر الاذاعه والتلفزيون جنوبها
وجنوب هذا هذا الحي مباشره يقع على سلاح
الطبي الذي يضم خلفه سلاح المهندسين وعدد
من الاسلحه هي تسكن في تلك
المنطقه هذه المنطقه ظلت تشهد في اشتباكات
ومنعوشات بشكل مستمر ما قاله لنا احد افرا
اسرتها بان ما جرى هو كان قضاء وقدر ان
جزء من مغذوف سقط واطالها هي البقيه لم
يصفهم اذى قال بانه لم تصب باي رصاصه كما
يتم تداوله انه لا يوجد استهداف او عمل
شخصي راى انه يجري هو كان محضر قضاؤه قدر
طيب وكيف ردت فعل الشارع السوداني
طيب شاهدي هل سامعني كنت بسالك عن رده فعل
الشارع السوداني طبعا احنا في تاخير في
وصول الصوت لك بس بحاول الان اتاكد اذا
سامعني اي تفضل
نعم اسمعك الشارع السوداني تلقى خبر
وفاتها بحزن كبير جدا
وجدت جماهيريه طاقيه في السنوات التي
برزت فيها بداتك مقنيه وشاعره اقنت لي
السلام مظل التنبض الحرب منخرطت فيه ثوره
ديسمبر التي انهت نظام حكم الرئيس عمر عمر
البشير كذلك نالت شهره واسعه من خلال
تقنيها
بالايقاعات
التراثي التراثيه هنا في السودان قنه
المردوم قنه الله الطنبور قنه يعني قنت
بعدد من الايقاعات المحليه ظلت تنادي
السلام ظلت تنبض الحرب عرفت هنا في
السودان الحكامه هذا لقب اطلقوا عليها
جمهورها وهي في الغرفه السوداني تعني
المراه التي تقول الشعر وتمجد القيم
الفاضله منك ومن شجاعه ومن مروءه وخلافه
الشارع يعني تلقى هذا هذا الخبر بموجه حزن
كبيره جدا انتهبت او وسائط التواصل
الاجتماعي حزن كبير جدا على رحيلها كان
رايها واضحا منذ منذ بدايه هذه الحرب
بانها تقف ضد الحرب بشكل عام هي عاشر هذه
الحرب بين طفولتها في اقليم كردفان كما
ذكرتي في بدايه تعريفك هي عاشت هناك تعرف
ما معنى الحرب تذوقت ويلاتها لذلك هنا كان
رايها واضحا منذ البدايه بانها لن تدعم اي
طرف انها تقف ضد الحرب من حيث المبدا نحن
نشكرك على هذه المداخله وهذه التوضيحات
وطبعا
رحم الله شادن وشكرا لك كان معنا من
الخرطوم الصحفي في قناه العربيه شهد نادر
شكرا لك
من يومين رحل عن عالمنا الصوت الجريح
الفنان الكويتي القدير عبد الكريم عبد
القادر عن عمر 81 سنه بعد صراع مع المرض
وبعد اكثر من 60 سنه فنقدم خلالها اجمل
الاعمال الراحل شيع الى مثواه الاخير في
جنازه مهيبه وحضور كبير
وغير الحضور في الجنازه منصات التواصل
امتلات بالتعازي بوفاه الراحل وخاصه من
كبار الفنانين مشاهدينا احنا في تفاعلكم
وصلنا الى ختام حلقتنا اليوم نترككم مع
هذه التحيه منا في تفاعلكم
للراحل الكبير رحمه الله ونعود ونلقاكم
غدا ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
علينا
يا حلو
[موسيقى]
خلاص خلاص
عافك الخاطر خلاص وط
ني
وطن
[موسيقى]
النهار
ارجع يا كل الحب ارجع يا روحي
ارجع رمى محتاج
لايامك الحلوه
يا روح
[موسيقى]
الروح